hello Ukraine and Russia are accusing
each other of blowing up a major Dam
flooding towns and Villages and
russian-controlled territory Downstream
in the Harrison region water levels have
risen as much as 11 meters in the area
thousands of people have been evacuated
the Nova kakova Dam links the banks of
the danipro river held by Russia in the
South to Ukrainian Health territory in
the north IT Supplies water to the
Crimean Peninsula and cools the zaparita
nuclear power plants though the iaea
says it faces no immediate risk Charles
Stratford begins her coverage from
zapparicio
until Monday the kakovka dam held back
18 billion cubic meters of water
generating electricity and providing
fresh water for hundreds of thousands of
people but not anymore
the most immediate impact is for the
tens of thousands of civilians living
Downriver
this is the ukrainian-controlled side
the river swollen and overwhelming the
banks residents of the nearby streets
being evacuated from the rising water
I was evacuated
our local school and Stadium downtown
were flooded the stadium was completely
underwater and the flood waters were
reaching the schools on the Russian
occupied side of the river the town of
novakakovka is also under a meter or
more of flood water Ukraine's president
accused the Russians of terrorism
the whole world will know about this
Russian war crime the crime of ecocide
such deliberate destruction by the
Russian occupiers of the dam is an
environmental bomb of mass destruction
the world should show now that Russia
cannot get away with such Terror this is
the reservoir Upstream from the
destroyed Dam and it is a vast body of
water we estimate that the banks that
you can see behind me in the distance
are around 25 kilometers away the locals
that we've spoken to here say that they
reckon that the water level today has
dropped anywhere between a meter and two
meters and we expect in the coming hours
and days for the level to continue drop
thing and on that basis one can only
imagine the kind of devastating effect
that it is having on affected areas
south of the dam
Russian officials gave conflicting
accounts of denial some saying the dam
had burst on its own most pointed the
finger of blame back at Ukraine
in trying to prevent the offensive
operations by the Russian army along
this section of the front line the key
of regime committed an act of sabotage
or a terrorist act it led to the
flooding of substantial areas and will
have serious and long-lasting
environmental consequences
before and after satellite imagery again
reveals the extraordinary extent of the
deluge
the sluice Gates of the dam have been
gushing water since late last year when
Russia ended its occupation of the city
of kerzon and withdrew its troops across
the danipro river
Russian forces kept control of the dam
itself and have previously destroyed the
road running along the top of it for
Russia you can see the
to get across and also I would say that
if they're not planning on staying there
for the long term for whatever reason if
they think for example that they're not
going to win this battle then they would
leave Ukraine with this long-term
headache
Ukrainian infrastructure has been
attacked since the start of the war
Crane's counter-offensive is taking the
war into a new phase and with dramatic
consequences Charles Stratford Al
Jazeera zapparesia
well journalist Julia chapovalova has
the reaction from Moscow
it's Russia's investigative committee
has launched a criminal case into the
destruction of the Dan of the kahovska
power station calling it a terrorist
attack Kremlin spokesperson Dmitry
beskov has said that the destruction of
the kahovska station is a deliberate
sabotage from Ukraine therefore all the
responsibility for the situation should
be on Ukraine Russia rejected all the
allegations of its involvement in that
tag he also added that the destruction
of the dam had been carried out by Kiev
because it's counter-offensive couldn't
achieve any goals according to peskov
one of the goals of the Ukrainian
sabotage was to deprive the Crimean
Peninsula water meanwhile Russia's
defense minister called the dam incident
a terrorist attack and that it was
committed in order to prevent the
offensive actions of the Russian Armed
Forces according to shoigu the Ukrainian
Army had launched a long promised
offensive in several parts of the front
in the course of the last three days and
he announced that 71 Russian military
personnel had died during those past
three days Maria zaharo at the foreign
Ministry spokesperson wrote in her
telegram channel that Russia had warned
U.N security U.N Secretary General
rather Antonio Gutierrez about Ukraine's
intentions to destroy the kahovsky
station and now it's worth asking him
about what was done to prevent the
disaster
Yuri sack is an advisor to Ukraine's
Minister of Defense he says their
investigation shows Russia is to blame
for the destroyed them
our defense intelligence already has
evidence and proof of the fact that this
was a pre-planned man-made
artificial technological disaster a
terrorist act and when the time comes
and when the international war crimes
tribunal is set up of course all this
evidence will be put before it there are
of course some parts of this
hydroelectric Dam which cannot be
inspected by Ukrainian side because they
are now flooded and before that they
were under control of the aggressor but
at the same time
I don't think we can actually have a
presumption of innocent when we speak of
terrorists who have been indicted
already by the international criminal
court these are the same terrorists who
are lying to us on a daily basis about
everything about the gaining control in
Bahamut about their losses about their
gains we are confident and we have shown
already that it was impossible for
Ukrainian side to do anything with this
damn the destruction of dams as well as
other critical objects of infrastructure
is definitely a war crime under the
Geneva conventions article 56 if I'm not
mistaken so in reality you know I've
already said there will be an
international war crimes tribunal and at
the moment there are actually 38 States
who have expressed their willingness to
set up such a tribunal to try the war of
aggression and to try all other war
crimes
well the United Nations security Council
has held an emergency meeting to discuss
the collapse Dam in her son the U.N
warned that hundreds of thousands of
people on both sides of the front line
could be affected both Russia and
Ukraine use the session to blame each
other our diplomatic editor James Bays
reports from the U.N
morning the UN Secretary General Antonio
Gutierrez was quick to express his
concern about the gravity of the
situation following the Dam's collapse
the United Nations has no access to
Independent information on the
circumstances that led to the
destruction but when seeing is clear
this is another devastating consequence
of the Russian invasion of Ukraine in a
hastily convened security council
meeting both Russia and Ukraine blamed
each other for the destruction occurring
in a still evolving situation
it is physically impossible to blow it
up somehow from the outside by selling
it was mined by the Russian occupiers
and they blew it up
Russia's Ambassador had earlier told me
that makes no sense at all why would we
do it and besides the ukrainians was
threatening to ruin the damn long time
including a fishery they were saying it
openly to the Press Ukraine's closest
allies made it clear that while
information still being gathered the
ultimate blame must rest with Russia but
let's not forget the key fact here and
that's Russia invaded Ukraine it is
occupying the territory including that
Dam it controlled and so that's the
important Point here Russia needs to get
his troops out of Ukraine so far none of
the members of the security Council have
asked the UN Secretary General to set up
a formal U.N inquiry into what happened
and any such inquiry would be extremely
difficult given that the Dam's location
is still in an active conflict Zone
James Bay's Al Jazeera of the United
Nations